No,
Nah,
not really.
I mean,
it's funny.
I,
I don't,
again,
maybe because I don't think about,
I don't think about it enough.
Um,
it's funny because I now live in New
Jersey and,
uh,
I,
you know,
I've just start,
I've just moved out there and I'm
experimenting with,
with,
with the great commute.
And so I'm taking a train from the outer
still somewhat pastoral suburbs into
Manhattan and on that train ride,
um,
between the towns of [inaudible] and far
hills,
I was looking out the window the other
day and I looked out the window and
they're on the tops of this abandoned
line of telephone poles that were in
between the fields and,
and the kind of no man's land of the
track on these abandoned telephone
poles,
which dated to probably around 1900
where these gorgeous turquoise and jade
green colored glass insulators on the
Poles.
And these were what they used to,
you know,
protect the wiring.
Now these glass insulators stopped being
used in 1915,
1920 being actively made and they
switched into more one more modern
materials to protect these.
And I looked at this absolute,
you know,
almost,
it predates the machine age.
I looked at this glass,
these glass insulators,
and I have,
I've been collecting them for years.
So to see them out the window still in c
two as they would say,
I'm still in their original,
you know,
moment was,
was just so gratifying.
And so it was like the,
it was like the best moment of the week
for me because although part of me wants
to now go out there and climb up the
telephone poles and like try and extract
them because I'm like,
well,
no one's using them.
This is just,
it's no different than hunting for old
bottles.
I could be arrested,
but you know,
I've got to check with the local Amtrak
police there.
But I think the thing is,
is that if you look at those insulators
on those poles,
and you see how folks designed something
truly beautiful to protect the
technology of the time,
there was this glass case that went over
the ones and it was a very about the
function because they had to keep the
water out to stop the,
uh,
the wires from corroding.
But these are gorgeous.
And I know folks out there who have
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
different examples of these glass,
you know,
glass pieces.
And so seeing something like that,
an artifact from the early era,
seeing that out in that kind of,
you know,
I love looking at a train because we're
always looking at people's backyards.
And when you look out there and you see
these,
these ornaments that served a function
made me think about design again in a
fresh way.
But maybe it made me want to just go out
and get them.
Oh,
I don't know.
That's my style.